when I go to movie say to myself don't
eat all the things that they offer you
there I sit down at the movie starts
like popcorn soda love eating popcorn my
mom gets mad at me because I put too
much butter on the popcorn and then we
talk about it like three days later I'm
a Twizzlers person there's a whole
family size pack I like to sit in this
bag I really appreciate assigned seating
like the predictable nature of it it's
too easy
in the bathroom I'm a bad guy over
everybody I smoke weed in the parking
lot and then I buy a lot of candy after
that Sweetarts enjoy hamburgers hot dogs
I like the jalapeno hot dog that they
sell at the ArcLight with the watermelon
barbecue sauce but I asked for the
mustard as well because I'm a pig I
finish it off with a little caramel
popcorn I get started on the popcorn I
can't stop the dill pickle fan I like to
sit about two-thirds of the way up in
the middle I can't sit up close it's too
intimate do appreciate sitting right up
front and just let
it matters the movie though widescreen I
want to back up you catch all of it I
like in the middle I always get
mozzarella cheese sticks and a huge big
large club soda chicken McNuggets I like
to SAP the audience in front of me
because I like to watch them react
always sit in the back I do like to sit
in the back
popcorn like to mix with M&Ms
immediately peanut M&Ms
if you crunch them down like until it's
like a pace and then you put the popcorn
your mouth hungry or not wanted or not
it doesn't matter big handful yes
perfect combination Brussels
I'd love to eat popcorn you know like a
small and then a Sierra Mist I like to
sit right in the centre if somebody
hasn't taken that seat already the large
popcorn for one there's no it anywhere
where there's not a soiled seat I like
to sit on the aisle because I like to
know where the exit sign is that just
comes from working bad bars
I have nothing compared to that I just
sit there to watch the movie what am i
doing wasting my life like a schmuck
[Music]